so what's happening in ukraine whatever
its scale
and it's not totally clear right now but
whatever it is it's a tragedy because
war always is a tragedy and the closer
you get to it the more horrifying
it seems it's the ugliest thing that men
do ever
vladimir putin started this war so
whatever the context of the decision
that he made he did it he fired the
first shots he is to blame for what
we're seeing tonight in ukraine
the question is once we've established
that and it's obvious how should the
united states respond to what he has
done
so within minutes of the outbreak of the
war last night the usual liars on
television began leveraging this tragedy
for partisan political gain
if you ever watch the aftermath of a
school shooting you're familiar with how
they behave it's contemptible but we're
going to ignore it tonight because there
is too much else going on that actually
matters and the main thing that matters
in any crisis is deciding
what's most important creating a
hierarchy of concern
so until last night the main purpose of
our foreign policy was to prevent russia
from invading ukraine obviously that
failed
at some point we should figure out why
but what's our top goal now well there's
several of them here are the first three
first and most obviously avoid a
full-scale war with a nuclear-armed
adversary
and to be fair very few people in
washington want anything like that war
with russia is so obviously a bad idea
but that doesn't mean we won't have one
wars often break out accidentally or
more often incrementally things escalate
and the next thing you know you've got
verdun with many thousands dead
now that shooting has started in ukraine
it is entirely possible no matter what
they assure you that americans could
wind up getting hurt in eastern europe
we should prevent that but preventing it
will require wisdom and farsightedness
and emotional control all of which are
never in abundant supply in washington
and especially now that everyone is
justifiably upset again what russia has
done is awful
but we could still make it worse
mark warner the head of the senate
intelligence committee just announced
that russia could be potentially close
to triggering what's known as article 5
of the nato alliance that's a collective
defense principle so if russia were to
launch a cyber attack on ukraine warner
explained an attack that affects nearby
nato members like poland or lithuania
then possibly every nato country
including ours united states
would be obligated to declare war on
russia here he is explaining
one of the things that i'm gravely
concerned about is if russia unleashes
its full cyber power
against ukraine once you put malware
into the wild in a sense
it knows no geographic boundaries so if
the russians decide they're going to try
to turn off the power
uh turn off all the electricity all
across ukraine very likely that may turn
off the power in eastern poland and east
romania that could affect our troops if
suddenly hospitals are shut down if
those nato troops american troops
somehow have a
car accident because the the stop lights
don't work
we are suddenly in an area of
hypothetically an article 5 where one
nato country is attacked we all have to
come to each other's aid
so warner is certainly right that could
add that hypothetical that he outlined
could happen any cyber attack on ukraine
could well affect the infrastructure of
the eastern european countries that
would be bad it would be a crime a
civilized world would deplore it but
article 5 is not a mechanical mechanism
human beings have to decide to invoke it
and the question is
is what the senator just described
something that is worth risking a
nuclear conflict over
and that is something we should pause
very deeply to think about in the most
sober possible way and we hope that our
leaders are
but not all of them seem sober right now
some of them seem reckless and as usual
ignorant
congressman adam kinziger of illinois
for example spends a lot of time on
cable television talking about world
affairs he seems like an expert and yet
by temperament he's certainly the last
person you want anywhere near a nuclear
button today kinzinger informed us that
russia's seizure of the defunct
chernobyl plant might quote trigger
article 5.
okay it could be interpreted that way
and then what happens
clearly adam kinziger hasn't thought
about that not for a moment so you see
the problem here the question is not
who's at fault we can say that vladimir
putin is at fault for what happened last
night
but then what
and that's the larger problem once
conflict starts especially when that
conflict is televised
it's really hard to know what happens
next so anyone who thinks the invasion
of ukraine couldn't become a world war
either lacks imagination or is lying to
you it certainly could become a world
war so that's the first goal not making
a terrible thing much much worse
here's the second goal keep the energy
flowing
cheap energy we take it for granted but
it is the basis of all we have no energy
no civilization
unfortunately a huge percentage of
europe's energy now comes from russia
and ukraine the european union relies on
russia for roughly 40 of its natural gas
in germany which is one of the biggest
economies in the world that percentage
is over half most of its energy in the
form of natural gas comes from russia
and ukraine
so you don't hear that very often on
television this debate is framed
exclusively in moral terms and those are
important we shouldn't ignore them but
they're not the only terms we should
consider the fact is that vladimir putin
has the power to send europe and for
that matter potentially the united
states into an economic depression putin
has the power to turn off the lights
so where did vladimir putin get this
power
well there are a lot of reasons but a
big reason is the climate people gave
him this power thanks to pressure from
zealots like john kerry europe has been
shutting down nuclear power plants for
years
and that's a very confusing strategy
if you're worried about climate nuclear
energy is not the problem nuclear energy
is the solution it's reliable it's
domestically produced it emits no carbon
so if you were genuinely worried about
temperature rises global warming you
would embrace nuclear energy
but our leaders and not just ours
globally across the west have done the
opposite why maybe their donors and
families are invested in so-called
renewable technologies who knows
whatever the reason
because of a series of very specific
decisions made over time the west is now
dangerously dependent on vladimir putin
for energy
now our leaders may act like this is not
a big deal it is definitely a big deal
and we ought to make decisions based on
that fact
and finally a topic no one ever brings
up we must protect the u.s dollar
america's power derives from its wealth
rich countries get to do what they want
poor countries must obey their masters
or they get invaded we just saw that
happen that is the unchanging rule
in this country control of the us dollar
is the key to our wealth our entire
financialized debt-based economy rests
on the unique privilege of issuing the
world's reserve currency
if the u.s dollar is ever replaced we
are in legitimate trouble
our debt will come due our government
will go bankrupt and millions of
americans will become poor immediately
so this is the main thing we ought to be
worried about and it is a greater risk
now than ever before sanctions are an
emotionally satisfying way to punish
someone like vladimir putin who clearly
does deserve to be punished no one's
really against sanctions
but the question is do they work
clearly multiple sanctions did not
prevent last night's invasion of ukraine
let's start there
at the same time sanctions give russia
and many other countries across the
world a strong incentive to dump the us
dollar which is the means by which we
enforce sanctions
so last summer for example in a story
that most people didn't pay enough
attention to russia in response to
sanctions completely removed the u.s
dollar its assets from its sovereign
wealth and its national wealth fund
the chinese noticed they understand
exactly how this works and in their
effort to displace the united states
they are strongly in favor of it china
is trying to become the first major
country in the world whose central bank
issues sovereign digital currency
if that works and many efforts like it
it would be a huge loss for the united
states an irreplaceable loss that would
change this country forever much more
than an invasion of ukraine
so we should be watching that attacks on
the primacy of the us dollar globally
every bit as intently as we watch the
coverage currently on television of the
hot war
if at the end of this conflict whenever
that is countries around the world have
come to see the chinese uen as a
stronger more stable currency than the
us dollar
then this country will have lost more
than we understand somebody needs to be
paying attention to this
let's fervently hope that somebody is
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else